yeah thanks dr. Wallach I've got um 65
years old and six foot tall and weigh
about 70 kgs yes I'm sorry
yeah you're here about 150 pounds okay
and so yeah you're very slim it at six
foot four well what else you got going
on I'm good I get a lot of congestion a
lot of phlegm I've got a bad memory
oh you have a dry very dry coughs first
thing in the mornings for quite some
time give me any problems do something
big pardon any skin problems like dry
skin or eczema dermatitis no I guess I
get some like dandruff or joy okay
enough these yeah do you have any bowel
problems any constipation or diarrhea
colitis or anything like that
no no I'm pulling me okay have any
brothers and sisters
oh yeah
uncle them list okay do any of them have
any of these problems not that I know of
no okay so your main complaint is a
congestion and dry cough and also now
you have a memory problem correct
okay so Charmaine you there I'm here I'm
working here we're going to do for Wally
first of all I think he needs to gain a
little bit of weight at six foot four I
like the same way at least 180 to 210
somewhere in there okay needs to gain 30
40 50 pounds also I like him to be able
to breathe properly and so what can we
do for him
well for the issues what I would do is I
would take a healthy brain in her back
and I would add the synaptic to it and I
would add the killer biotic okay well
let's ago it says so gotta give it all
the bad foods yeah a no fried foods no
process means no oils uh gluten got to
give it all in the inflammatory stuff
and I want you to think about absorption
if you have to have a high efficient
absorbance no bad there's no fried foods
processed meats oils and glutens
Charmaine you said 150 pounds I don't
have them take two of the healthy brain
and heart packs per month a full dose of
everything twice a day and also that's
going to give him plenty of the EFA zfa
pluses to support healthy respiration
and that sort of stuff also reduces the
risk of blood clots and then I would
also throw in the Z radical two quarts a
month so you take an ounce of breakfast
ounces dinner the Z radical is made from
four super juices and if you Clayton
and they took Clayton is a substance
found in red marine algae off the coast
of Australia and it is credited by the
Japanese as the reason why they have
about a third the cancer rate we do and
why they have such a much higher rate of
cancer survivor' let me do really good
to support the immune system and what
would you do for the coffee's got a dry
cough what what would you give him safe
from our aromatherapy division to
support healthy respiration and reduce
like sore throats and that kind of thing
so he can breathe easier well Raven
serves one thing and okay you know and
he could take the killer biotic if it's
you know yeah yeah you also take the
killer bonding through those capsules
twice today to see miles a month Ravens
here is a great one for respiratory
problems also breath of life throw those
things in there and then give us a call
every couple of weeks Wally will walk
you through this it sounds pretty
straightforward and we look forward to
giving a great testimony